one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle welcome to
Japan
[Music]
now when I first came here to Japan my
first contract was in Osaka so I've been
doing modeling here for about two months
and I met a few interesting people I got
my signature up on a famous restaurant
and I also did a couple of modeling jobs
some went quick and I had to go to my
next contract in Tokyo
[Music]
hey hey hey good morning here from Tokyo
so what is it like for foreigners to do
modeling here in Japan well let's start
with the mortal apartment this is my
model apartment right it's a kind of
bachelor flat and my model agency here
gave me a few options to choose from and
I chose this apartment because it's a
little bit bigger it's more expensive
than the other ones but it's a nice
recording apartment for my videos
because we got these nice windows right
here where I get the natural light from
you know so it's a little bit small all
the apartments here are very small in
Japan and this is probably one of the
best that you can get so this is a nice
kind of closet that you have and you can
put your stuff in I have two so you I do
have some nice space over here then nice
a TV over here that I'm not really using
at all this is my office so this is
where I said edit and work on the videos
through here that's where you go outside
into Japan
and where you're not allowed to wear
your shoes in the apartment so you can
see down here that's where my shoes are
you can put it in there as well I kind
of like that because it'll keeps the
apartment nice and clean it's a lot of
funny rules as well for example this one
that's a little bit crazy having a guest
or a friend stay overnight without
informing us and they use this picture
so over here we got the kitchen now with
cutlery and stuff you don't have an oven
you don't really have a lot of stuff
that's very sad because I love cooking I
like making healthy food myself so yeah
firstly you don't have a lot of cool
things this is the toilet area so very
small
and then here yeah very small this is it
this is the model apartment all right so
here of Andrea your animals you have
ants on so guys what do you like about
modeling in Japan and what don't you
like well first of all I like the fact
that they bring this by car to the
casting something that normally we don't
have this guy because normally we have
to walk by ourselves where we go in the
world
the second thing obviously is that being
independent either from here easily
wherever we find it it's very healthy
and doesn't like that say go against our
diets so it's all positive negative
actually I don't have something negative
about it
I really think about something that's
pretty cool on top
what do you like yeah I gotta agree with
them that the fact that everything so
organized over here with the castings
would job everything your work schedule
it's just so much easier you know if you
compare it to other countries where you
work and yeah that's definitely
something that we appreciate what being
over here yeah yeah negative things it's
my first trip so right now I don't
really have much negative experience
over here right now oh it's alright okay
another thing I noticed your Egypt
panties they have very very young models
so what do you guys feel how do you feel
about the young girls like 14 15
probably they should stay home and study
how I feel but you know and the world is
big and you don't know what's their
reality their situation back home and
maybe some of them with the money they
make here we probably like provides to
their families yeah all right
where are the casting gear not so we're
gonna get going but uh maybe I'll make a
video talking a little bit more about
that as well a little bit more about the
dark side
[Music]
hey guys I'm here with Chris I've met
him a few years ago around five years
ago I think yeah
in another modeling contract and is so
nice because I met him here again in
Japan and I would love for you to just
share with them what do you like about
modeling in Japan and what don't you
like basically I love everything about
working here they are super polite they
are always on time super professional
they know what they want the locations
the the closest the products are always
good quality yeah you're always treated
like kind of gods and you have always
good food really good and what don't you
like
what is lime you can be honest there's
not really a big thing it's just that as
a German you're really direct and there
are always sneaking it around and be too
polite they don't want to be
disrespectful is I'm thankful that you
do a bad job but I don't take it as a
bad job I just want the efficiency so
it's just okay this doesn't work out do
something else and don't yeah got it
yeah I feel the same way sometimes
they're very very kind and they don't
want to be disrespectful so even if they
don't like something they'll be like um
but we prefer it if they just directly
say please change that angle a little
bit we prefer it this way yeah so you
can work much faster hmm yeah so
basically that's it all right
the model agencies here in Osaka they
don't want me to record anything that's
got to do with the jobs about them or
anything I understand where they're
coming from because they want to keep it
professional
and most of them when I first arrived
they haven't actually checked out any of
my videos today I have no idea about my
style and there's a lot of crazy
youtubers out there a lot of crazy
youtubers out there so in a contract I
respected their wishes I'm not recording
anything of it but I can show you a
little bit of my work here so what are
the requirements to come and do modeling
here as a foreigner well for girls they
mostly like cute girls it's slowly
changing as well because I've seen some
very unique very interesting models as
well but they do not like older models
so I haven't seen one girl here that's
over 24 25 ish most of them here are
around 17 16 18 which is very very very
young the best height the height that
you need to be as around 1.75 and you
need to be very skinny so for guys it's
a little bit different for guys they
like guys from all ages young guys
middle-aged guys like me and then older
guys that's even above 50 you cannot be
very big here so I had to lose a few
kilos I had to slim down a bit I stopped
working out for a while just to lower
even just my chest to 95-96 otherwise
it's too big to fit their clothes and
then I conveyed the builds and the
height requirement is a little bit
different here because it most overseas
countries they like one eight seven one
eight six one eight a that's fine but
here in Japan they like 185 so they like
a little bit shorter models as well one
I'd for you
alright let's talk about the model
agencies what is it like to work with
the modeling agencies here in Japan well
for me I experienced two agencies one in
Osaka and one here in Tokyo and they are
some of the friendliest people and
professional most professional people
that you will work with they're actually
better to work with than most other
agencies in the world because they're
very kind and very considerate they're
always punctual always on time
they understand your situation they have
empathy for you and they're very good at
their jobs now the worst thing for me is
when I see new and young models coming
here to Japan and some of them are very
disrespectful you know because Japan is
a very respectful country and I I have a
lot of love for Japan and the people
just because they are so kind and so
respectful towards even people from the
outside and to each other but some of
the models that come here are so
inconsiderate and the way that I do
things is just mind-blowing especially
the younger ones so if you come to Japan
respect them and respect the culture
[Music]
alright let's talk about the jobs here
in Japan because that's also important
right so the type of jobs that you can
do in Tokyo is a magazine to get TV
commercials you have events fashion
shows you have all the basic kind of
jobs here in Tokyo but in Osaka it's a
little bit different because there's not
so many TV commercials but there is more
wedding type photoshoots so it changed a
lot here in Japan this is my second time
here and there seems to be a little bit
more agencies here and a lot more models
so the competition is a lot more than it
used to be so it's a little bit it's
tougher to really make money but that is
looks like that's what's happening in
the whole world now so it's becoming
harder and harder to make a good living
off of just traveling and doing modeling
so most models I think the biggest
reason why people still continue to be
models is just the opportunity
to travel they'll have the experience to
travel to all these different countries
and experience living with these
cultures for two to three months and
it's different from just being a tourist
and making a quick trip you know you get
this opportunity of really traveling the
world but the opportunity to make a lot
of money isn't it's not how it used to
be a couple of years ago I believe me
I've been doing this for 13 years and
when I started it was a lot easier and a
lot better to make money the lifestyle
here in Japan is awesome I love the
people I love the culture and there's
just so much that you can do here in
Japan
[Music]
hey guys good morning here from Japan
now I'm gonna meet up with a few friends
we're gonna have some sushi from a real
monster ship so I'm super excited are we
gonna show you guys how you should eat
sushi the right way we're gonna show you
a few other stuff as well but let's get
to it
[Music]
alright guys finally here what my
friends are we gonna go to the
traditional sushi place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]